Хто це якщо ви відкриєте біографію цієї
конкретної людини ви побачите що так
міжнародні відносини Так дипломатія там
якісь інвестиційні фонди там помічник
завгоспа в офісі президента але
Перепрошую Ця людина не має
анічогісінько дотичного до оборони
держави в контексті знань як вести
бойові дії як злагоджувати війська як
тримати оборону І тим паче я наголошу що
нас напевне в офісі президента забулося
у нас воєнний стан тобто відповідно
максимум повноважень мають саме
військові генеральний штаб приймати ті
чи інші рішення і робити ті чи інші
заяви і явно не якомусь там 10000му не
недекларованому раднику офісу президента
коментувати слова головнокомандувача
Яким є Валерій залужний
перше другий момент Якщо зараз глянути
на telegram-канали банкової і і
прикормлених так званих блогерів вони
зараз масовану атаку роблять на Валерія
залужного і це є абсолютно гедотно в
контексті того що Валерій залужний є
головнокомандувачем збройних сил України
і будь-які ось такі наїзди на
головнокомандувача причому що він має
право говорити що він не має право
говорити як він взагалі має право в
науковій статті щось там заявляти це
означає що влада почала бавитися в
політику і політичні впливи а це є Ну
величезна проблема для воюючої держави
тому що це означає що політика начхати
на безпеку і оборони держави точніше
політикам прив'язаним до банкової Тобто
всі хто оточують Володимира Зеленського
третій момент Ну напевно ці ідіоти
інакше не скажу не читали статті Валерія
залужного а їх просто задрало те що він
посмів щось публічно сказати особливо
після страшно невдалої статті в ймс
Причому я так розумію проплаченою
банковою ну це моя думка тому що ніхто
без відома банкової не міг би так
близько підійти до президенти і
спілкуватися з ним як цей конкретний
журналіст Тайм а Валерій залужний в
надзвичайно системний сухий наголошу
науковий спосіб визначив які у нас є
проблеми і визначив які мають бути шляхи
вирішення цих проблем і чесно кажучи для
будь-якого кваліфікованого політика чи
лідера іншої якоїсь закордонної держави
це якраз дуже чітка си чіткий системний
підхід а як можуть допомогти Україні і
от я чесно кажучи була захоплена цією
статтею вона складна її треба не один
раз перечитати щоби зрозуміти про що
йдеться я наголошу не колонку а саме
статтю на яку посилається The economist
він там наголошує на раціональні
організації логістичного забезпечення си
сил оборони держави з цим є проблема є
величезна проблема американці нам ще
доторгнення казали про розвиток
сеологістики який є основною складовою
зрештою сил НАТО він говорить що
потрібно приймати на озброєння ракети
збільшого збільшеного радіусу дії
причому бажано власного виробництва
звичайно команду Зеленського це так
знаєте як під дих отримати тому що вони
в 19-му році зупинили це виробництво
вони до сих пір нормально його не
налагодили постачання цих ракет зокрема
конкретно стугни немає достатньої
кількості він наголошує на концепції
накопичення ресурсів у нас же ж по суті
зараз все йде з коліс і з тим є
дуже-дуже складно він наголошує на
важливості використання сучасних
інформаційних технологій в системі
управління і ось ці от всі речі Вони є
базовими для держави яка воює і якщо
керівництво цієї держави цього не
розуміє Ну значить Питання в тому що
можли моливо керівництво А треба чи
міняти чи керівництву ставити блок на в
контексті впливу на рішення військових
тому що ні Зеленський ні Жовква ні купа
тих всіх псевдоблогерів вони не йдуть зі
зброєю в руках фізично відвойовувати
свою землю ідуть наші бійці солдати
офіцери за яких відповідає Валерій
залужний особливо наголошуючи на тому що
кожна людина кожне людське життя кожний
боєць - це є величезна цінність і я
розумію що хтось там може вимагати
штурми Горлівки Авдіївки бахмуту для
афектації під конкретні дати Ну але у
нас немає такого людського ресурсу як
Московської Федерації і ми не маємо
права вести своїх хлопців і дівчат на
забій ми маємо використовувати знання
технології злагодженість щоби вони всі
були цілими живими і здоровими А ми мали
на ду перемагати саме про це говорить
Валерій залужний і кожний хто сьогодні
проти нього відкриває рота ми маємо
ставити галочку працює на диявола працює
на Московську федерацію працює там на
виборчий процес но точно не працює на
державу